heute startet unter anderem in berlin
wieder die schule doch wie gut ist die
hauptstadt eigentlich gerüstet nach
einer so langen corona pause für die
schule lehrer christopher sascha erklärt
uns die neuen maßnahmen also die
hygienepläne kommen von oben vom senat
und parallel dazu entwickelt die schule
natürlich hauseigene konzepte und der
kern dessen sind die abstandsregeln die
meisten pflicht bis zum unterricht raum
und dass die jahrgänge möglichst wenig
gemischt werden das heißt die
pausenzeiten wurden massiv
zusammengestrichen es gibt keine
frühstückspause mehr an dieser schule
und nur noch 5 minuten pausen so dass
die kids in der regel in ihren
klassenräumen verbleiben
die schüler darf anhalten das haben wir
sie direkt selbst gefragt ich glaube es
ist alles vorbereitet keine angst also
das wird schon werden
ja wenn man die maske weil ein
mindestabstand tragen kann dann sollte
man das tun wirklich dem virus da keine
chance zu geben also ich finde es nicht
so wohl wenden sie sich an um arme und
so weiter und ich fände es besser wenn
man hier zur schule geht weiß zu hause
kriegt die sache noch nicht richtig
fertig und kann mich auch nicht so gut
konzentrieren
ja als ich habe halt ein bisschen sorge
aber wenn man halt die kinder da
funktioniert und da geht es eigentlich
und jetzt ist mir peter wilke live aus
berlin zehlendorf zugeschaltet hallo
peter
wir haben gerade schon einige maßnahmen
gehört aber du hast noch weitere details
was geht denn noch an dieser schule ja
sie haben wir stehen hier direkt vor der
wilma rudolph oberschule in berlin
zehlendorf
wir haben mit lehrern mitschülern
gesprochen wie wir gerade gesehen haben
und die haben uns die maßnahmen noch mal
genau erklärt grundsätzlich gilt in
allen berliner schulen eine masten
pflicht im gebäude hier an dieser
oberschule gilt sie sogar bis zum platz
das heißt die schüler müssen die masten
bis zum platz tragen dürfen sie dann
ausziehen und müssen sie daneben würden
die den raum wieder verlassen an ihrem
platz anziehen
außerdem soll auch in allen berliner
schulen der raum einmal pro stunde
durchgelüftet werden damit die sohle
halt aus dem raum entfernt werden und so
entgegen für das infektionsrisiko
minimiert wird
außerdem standen in dem gebäude auch
überall desinfektions spender bereit und
für bestimmte unterrichtsfächer wie der
musikunterricht gelten spezielle ringen
so sollen zb musikinstrumente nach jeder
benutzung desinfiziert werden wenn
schüler singen müssen sie mindestens
zwei meter abstand halten
bei auftritten sogar vier meter und der
sportunterricht soll vorzugsweise
draußen stattfinden und peter du bist
seit heute morgen an der schule was
konntest du da beobachten wird sich an
hygiene regeln gehalten
ja im gebäude selber helfen werden die
hygieneregeln eigentlich sehr gut
umgesetzt also wir haben auch mit
schülern gesprochen berichtet in den
gängen ist es nicht zu voll haben wir
auch schon gehört da werden wird es so
abgestimmt dass die schüler die meiste
zeit im klassenraum verbringen und sich
da nicht zuviel begegnen dann haben uns
aber auch schüler berichtet das eben in
der mensa da werden die abstände nicht
so gut eingehalten worden da kann man ja
auch keine maske tragen wenn gegessen
wird heute war aber grundsätzlich noch
nicht so viel los weil die schüler heute
nur getrennt jeweils gekommen sind um
ihre stundenpläne zu kriegen da muss man
dann schauen wie es sich in den nächsten
tagen entwickelt wenn alle schüler auf
einmal da sind die eltern haben
teilweise große skepsis gezeigt ob das
alles so funktioniert dieser hygieneplan
weil eben in den klassenräumen selber
noch keine masten pflicht gilt das
wollen viele eltern anders und was uns
ganz besonders aufgefallen ist was
natürlich eigentlich gar nicht geht die
schüler die hier vor dem tor gewartet
haben
war natürlich die freude groß nach den
langen sommerferien und den vielen
zeiten wo man vorher voneinander
getrennt war durch corona sich jetzt
wieder zu sehen aber da haben viele
spieler sich umarmt küsschen links
küsschen rechts also da war die freude
groß aber das ist natürlich nicht im
sinne der chor ohne regeln und da muss
man sich dann fragen ob das so viel sinn
macht wenn drin so streng darauf
geachtet wird abstandsregeln masken
pflicht hände desinfizieren aber das
dann natürlich direkt hier vorm schultor
wieder alles egal ist